if their corruption in the attempt to
cover up their corruption leads to World
War III well then they go down as the
worst family in American history they're
the most corrupt do you think they're
the worst at hiding it at this point uh
that's a good question actually because
I think there's a distinct possibility
they're not the most corrupt but
um they are the most inept at their
corruption Hillary remember I'm giving
them lessons if she was if they were
actually paying attention yeah Clinton
would be yeah that's true was good at it
yeah remember when
you know if you came out and said that
the country was being run
by powerful pedophiles in the private
sector and in government they said you
were a conspiracy theorist oh yeah and
then they were like you're crazy you're
a lunatic you're a crackpot far right
conspiracy theorist and then Epstein and
then Maxwell and Maxwell got convicted
and is in jail and now they're like
committed suicide and they have a client
list of all of these high-profile heads
of state and government who were
flying around with this guy it's just
like but no one else has been prosecuted